Speaker 1: All right, starting today with some
genuinely very bad news for some horrible people,
Rudy Giuliani and Sidney Powell, two of Donald
Trump's former election fraud attorneys, although
to call them election fraud attorneys, suggests
that there might have been fraud, which we now
know there wasn't. But both Rudy and Sidney have
been subpoenaed by the Trump Riot Committee, the
House Committee investigating the Jan. six Trump
riots. This is very bad news for them and very
bad news for Trump and Sidney Powell has not been
having an easy go of it. Newsweek reporting Rudy
and Sydney subpoenaed by one six committee. Will
they comply? The House Committee investigating
the Jan. six riot has subpoenaed Rudy Giuliani,
Jenna Ellis, Sidney Powell and Boris Epshteyn,
all attorneys in the 2020 reelection campaign
of then-President Trump. It's unclear whether
any of them will comply. Many of Trump's former
associates, like Steve Bannon and Mark Meadows,
have not. Some have invoked the Fifth Amendment to
avoid testifying. The committee wrote in a Tuesday
evening tweet the four individuals advanced
unsupported theories about election fraud pushed
efforts to overturn election results or were in
direct contact with the former president. The Hill
likewise reporting on these subpoenas, saying that
the subpoena goes after the core of Trump's legal
team after the November 3rd election, a group
that prepared legal arguments following his loss
and pushed his baseless claims of election fraud
alongside campaign efforts under a focused on the
congressional certification. The select committee
is looking into the causes that contributed to the
violence on January six, including attempts to
promote unsupported claims of election fraud and
pressure campaigns to overturn the 2020 election
results. The subpoena to Giuliani focuses on his
ability to offer insight into Trump's state of
mind in the days around the riots, as well as his
work pushing fraud claims on TV and in courtrooms,
the committee wrote. You actively promoted claims
of election fraud on behalf of former President
Trump and sought to convince state legislators
to take steps to overturn the election. Ana
Cabrera from CNN reports that her that Sidney
Powells attorney says she will appear before the
January 6th committee and answer questions, but
that Powell also still believes there indeed was
election fraud. So this is potentially a really,
really big deal, and there's a few different
pieces to this that I think are important.
The first one is it's very clear that this if you
imagine concentric circles of sorts with Donald
Trump at the middle of that circle, the entire
probe is getting closer and closer to Donald
Trump himself. Now Sidney Powell, Rudy Giuliani
talking about, you know, records from Ivanka
Trump and I'm sorry from Eric Trump and Kimberly
Guilfoyle. And we're wondering, will they next go
to Ivana Trump and Don Jr.? What? What's going
on there? It's very clear that it's closing in,
but will anything come of it? The second piece of
this is the increasingly important timing of the
investigation into the Jan. six Trump riots,
and the reason that that's increasingly a factor
is that we are now only nine and a half
or so months from the 2022 midterms. Now,
as I've said before, I don't believe that any
October surprise stemming from the investigation
will really have an impact on the midterms.
I just I can't. It's hard for me to imagine
what could come out of the report that we don't
really kind of know already. And importantly,
that would change the way Republicans would vote
in the midterms. I don't think there would be
anything, but that doesn't change the fact that if
Republicans do take the House in November and are
sworn in in January, the entire investigation
is over. Overnight, the committees disbanded.
If Republicans take control of the House in
November, so it would be important even if it's
not going to change the minds of any Republicans
to have a finished report from the House Select
Committee on the Jan. six Trump riots before it's
prematurely ended. If Republicans indeed do take
control of the House in November, so those are the
considerations, and the committee does seem to be
moving relatively quickly as quickly as they can.
And the question of what to do about the people
ignoring the subpoenas is an important
question, and it takes time to resolve
that as the legal system functions and moves
forward much more slowly than we would like,
but not. A good day for Rudy Giuliani.
Not a good day for Sidney Powell, either.